figure because of course i did um i
didn't know if they started making them
already but apparently they did oh nice
i would have preferred
um roxy uh grey rat yes yes her name is
grey rats error screaming that's like
some like iron mouse copyright situation
honestly you look at that look at the
design
look at the design
[Laughter]
i can't believe iron mouse
copied from
so yeah this is um the lost member of v
shojo apparently uh eris
yeah
yeah i mean i mean i think uh i think
mushoka tensei is far and beyond the
best issac i've ever seen um so i just i
just wanted to i just wanted something
some presentation yeah some
representation
for the easter guys this is an anime i
started watching
has it actually yeah yeah isn't it so
good i finished season one the other day
oh bro yeah have we not talked about
this it's [ __ ] awesome dude i love it
it's such a good [ __ ] show sorry boys
i was pretty distracted that it [ __ ]
moves
that's so cool yeah that's the noise it
makes
he needs the [ __ ] gun with that yeah
he does yeah
there's a gun he's the big fuck-off gun
we don't need the gun right now it's
fine yeah can't believe we bought the
exact same figure we both lost two
points i'm not you know what the the
bike
i'm not even mad i'm not even mad
because you got the bike
i i committed i committed jerry it's all
right i'm taking you bro they got they
got the tinder pout down look at that
look at that it's it's it's the small
details man it's the small detail it's
all about the simple things
all right show off your figure guard huh
show it off to us
stop taking nine years to unbox it i'm
sorry connor i'm sorry rip it open rip
and tear
i thought you didn't do that with your
figures he's got google he's got google
maps on the [ __ ] bike yo let's go
google maps bro what the [ __ ] yo they
were thinking ahead
dude the detail is like insane yeah i
know
it is like model car
level off yeah but the light turns as
well oh that's so cool does it like does
the light turn on i don't know i don't
think so nice that's not bad yeah very
clean oh [ __ ] we have to actually build
it okay we probably can't do it now
yeah yeah
yeah show the camera it comes with a
bunch of uh different customizations
yeah yeah cool we can build that on
stream yeah yeah yeah okay do you want
to take this away i'll just leave this
on here for now i still have one more
figure by the way okay and it's the
biggest one i have
is it that one there's that one right
there do you want to we don't have to
unbox it now i have to unbox it just
just put the box on the thing
joe i didn't know you were a hatsune
miku fan what can i say i like anime
we've gotten to the point where the
figures we've bought we buy are so big
that it's actually blocking us yeah uh
so i'm not gonna unbox this but this is
the memorial dress uh hatsune miku
uh
uh for uh the anniversary
is it
there's the box yeah that one is also
the one that is closest to 420 for me
okay we'll so we'll uh funny enough the
one of the figures i have left is the
closest to 420 for me oh nice okay all
right
i don't know what the [ __ ] this is
it happened to be so close to 420. what
the [ __ ] is that
we've got two bikes
[Applause]
thank god i do not know what this is uh
this is
megazone23
i don't know what that is i'm guessing
it's like a super obscure yeah it's
probably a super old makeup show
where will i get it destroyed for
calling this the transformer because it
kind of looks like a transformer
so i'm guessing this is some very og
isn't garland like a different character
from a different show yeah it's final
fantasy right i'm guessing it's rare or
something because it's 420 dollars i
think it's like i think i think just
looking at the font of the show name it
looks like an old show uh in like the
mech section of amiami oh okay but like
that's what it looks like so i guess
yeah i don't wanna be here all day
opening for you guys yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so yeah we'll just take that off
stream good stuff that's my closest i
have one more uh how many do you have
left i'm done would you want to go first
i just went okay um so
uh oh you go first because this one's a
hentai thing well i thought my last
challenge was get something from an
anime
that the boys haven't watched
and what better than an anime that isn't
even out yet because there's no possible
way you could have watched it
oh nice
ark nights and i i was i was running
around the store and i thought there was
a few others haven't argued
yeah it's been announced announced yeah
and you haven't watched it we haven't
watched it
no one's seen it nobody's seen it except
for the people working on it so i
thought perfect and and you know me and
joey like arc knights i do i still play
i don't know
yeah i don't play it you didn't get the
chin one though obviously
i went for the more expensive one uh
okay but the challenge i know you like
this i i like chan more yeah why is the
four star no she is she's five stars
it's literally the first unit you get
yeah she's she's gonna repeat that she's
yeah yeah it's literally the default
unit yeah i don't even know how to open
it her like final e2 is like obvious
[ __ ]
yeah i'm sorry if you don't play arc
knights yeah well so this is the main
character from arc knights i'm guessing
she'll be in the anime as well i think
she'll be the main girl in the app yeah
um yeah that's so nice though because i
have uh i've seen the nendoroids of army
i don't like nendoroids
i i like nindoroids but i i really like
the nendoroids for amia but like a full
figurine of that i actually might go i
actually might go and buy this
like it's actually it's actually so nice
if there's one thing arc knights does
absolutely amazingly it's character
design yeah yeah i think i think there
is there is no better game that can do
better character design and it's [ __ ]
so cool
like i've been looking i've been eyeing
up some arc night figures that haven't
been released yet yeah um like
the e3 one that's coming out looks
[ __ ] amazing
yeah it's coming out next year oh i i
remember it for being super op yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
she's still open she's still open
well that's that's the arc okay that's
actually so cool i love that oh yeah
army is so cute dude
yeah well that's that was 150 bucks nice
i thought you know it's a complete a
challenge and it's a pretty good figure
yeah so what was your challenge again oh
yeah
you haven't seen it
we haven't seen it uh i haven't yet
unfortunately did the cut scenes in the
game
does the pv count until the
advertisements
i see the advertisements on the train
all the time yeah
yeah there you go i thought it was a
cool thing yeah you know what no
complaints uh that's a nice figure
all right
yeah so i've got one more figure and of
course amiami has like a really good
selection of hentai and lude figures
right yes so i wanted to get a hentai
figure
and i found the weirdest hentai figure
i've ever seen okay bet okay
so
on the front it looks like a normal
hentai figure right but the figure
is just an ass
i'm gonna have to blow that
it's literally just enough oh this is
like the this is like the way they get
sucked into a wall
stuck in the wall you only get half the
figure so it's just the ass gone how are
we going to display this i love that
display
oh my i love this so much it's amazing
but we can't show it guard how much
oh god it comes with uh it comes when it
comes with a it's an art book what the
[ __ ]
the history of it
oh all right all of this luckily i have
these
things uh covering me
but uh oh actually no it's it's actually
quite wholesome
yeah see this uh maybe not i'm gonna i'm
gonna have to uh i'm gonna have to
oh it's all of that box for that
wait for that
okay this art book is actually quite
awesome there's like some there's like
some nice artwork in here what's the
point of the artwork i think it's uh the
artwork done by the same guy maybe who
designed this figure or designed this
character that the figure is based off
of i mean the cover is like wow
yeah we can't show that and the back of
the book i guess is fine but uh yeah the
front is wow look at god's ava whoa
how much was that ava again got
oh it's getting gasoline holy [ __ ] look
at that ava it's getting filled up
here i've got room on my place i'll just
put it here i can't i don't know which
one the ava is i bought oh the ava one
is so cool
or maybe don't hold it like that yeah
that's the look at that look at that
it's getting filled up
[ __ ] yeah oh bro that's pretty sick
that's actually so sick all right enough
about the ava
what can you say
that's just that [ __ ]
that's actually [ __ ]
i love this why why would you want that
just you know
it's just dumb wait is there like a wall
attachment you can put on i think you
can put it on like your phone
so
you can you can do that
okay
that's actually hilarious
um this was
i believe uh 130 dollars
i would i would i would i i happily
would buy that for 130. if it was over
150 i'd have been like this it's just
that is one of the best things i've ever
seen
all right boys how much did you spend in
a miami total
i spent an army army
one thousand and seventeen dollars gone
how much did you spend uh
i spent a total of one thousand
five hundred and eighty dollars holy
crap at amiami jesus holy [ __ ] well
mostly it was on that right yeah well it
was like eight hundred dollars on a yeah
so yeah and you lost two points for it
but it was worth it because that was
worth it
right i was thinking
the bike is probably going to be the
most visibly like striking on the thing
because none of this [ __ ] can fit on the
desk
or there
i don't know i don't know you can fit
this thing
we can't show that
it's so funny
all right well that's amiami let's go to
the next store